let's talk about the other
um item that moth brought up at the
beginning where he was uh tabling
monogamy versus non-monogamy because one
of the things that a lot of guys come
across when they're on dating sites now
is ethical non-monogamy
um women are posting in their dating
profiles that they're you know they're
single but in some cases they're not
they're they're either married or they
have a boyfriend and they want to step
out of the relationship and they call it
ethical non-monogamy do you guys run
into this
um I assume most of you are all single
right
yes okay so do you guys ever run into
this when you're dating when you're
talking to guys like we're they're out
and about sort of
um scattering seed you know doing
whatever they want and you have that
conversation like how does that usually
work for you from your perspective uh
Nicole let's start with you yeah
um so I I live in the Bay Area uh we're
sort of the land of
everything goes um sexually that's like
Ground Zero isn't it we're like we're
like inventing all sorts of things over
here like we can't even keep up
um but I mean first of all I'm not going
out on dates with men who say that
they're ethically non-monogamous or
whatever
um and they generally openly listed in
their profile because they this is
something they genuinely want
um it's nothing I go near
at the same time am I surprised by it no
why because
monogamy is not for the faint of heart
like honestly monogamy is not easy it's
not easy for women it's not easy for men
if you can get yourself an arrangement
where it's like hey it's ethical we do
what we want it requires so much less
from each person in that relationship
um and so it's like it doesn't surprise
me you know that people are reverting
back to this because this isn't anything
new right before like the
judeo-christian idea of like of
monogamous marriage between a man and
woman like people were doing this all
the time this isn't like new to the
scene in 2023 this is like as old as
time so
um I'm not surprised by it you know
because it's it's the easy out but it's
nothing I don't hear so um
what's your expense um experience uh
Shania
um it's not so much
that I deal with people who are like oh
you know I'm in a relationship but it's
open it's just
so much so that people just aren't
looking for relationships right now so I
can't really say anything about it
because I don't have much experience
about it but isn't that what dating apps
are for like isn't that why they created
them to match people up
well that's the thing is that they're
not looking for like serious
relationships they just want to meet as
many people as they can
and then that's it so I don't know it's
kind of interesting to me to be on a
dating app because you know I like I
said before I'm looking for serious I'm
always a one-person kind of girl yada
yada and that seems to be rare nowadays
and so it is difficult to be on a dating
app with all these people going like oh
yeah not looking for anything serious
I'm open to dating multiple people
and all that and I don't know it's just
it's weird
um but I just also understand why people
do it I mean my old roommate was
polyamorous and so I had him explain it
to me and you know it does make sense to
some degree
um but
I don't know how do you how did he
explain it to you like what was his
angle uh so basically
um I might be wording it wrong but bare
minimum basic explanation is that there
was just no temptation and so if he was
with a partner and then he saw another
girl at a bar there was no like having
to hold himself yeah he didn't have to
hold himself back he was allowed to go
and pursue her and take her home or do
whatever
um and but still you know loved his
girlfriend talked with his girlfriend
about it all that stuff
um
yeah I think she also was polyamorous so
like they both did it
um but the one thing that was strange to
me is that they both had dating apps
which
I mean I feel like in that sense you're
searching for it or like if it happens
naturally like at a bar or like at a
show or something like that like then I
understand but when you're actively
searching for another hookup while you
also have a partner that always kind of
Nicole you said something interesting
that monogamy is hard for women too can
you explain that
yeah I think just
um monogamy in general for human beings
requires a lot more than non-monogamy
because I feel like non-monogamy is like
you know we look at the animal kingdom
non-monogamous you know it's everywhere
right but we have as humans like we have
higher reason
um and we're able to develop virtues in
ways that place us like above the level
of merely animals so monogamy is it's
it's just more difficult and in how is
it more difficult for women as well well
because women
women can stray women can be
dissatisfied women can be lonely like
women can experience all the emotions
that men experience and
um so while it looks different because
men and women are different and our
Temptations may come to us in different
forms
um you know I think like Shania said
I mean the couple said it they're like
oh there's no temptation which to me I
hear there's no temptation I hear oh
there's no self-control oh there's no
desire for virtue oh there's no
difficulty and so the problem there is
that those two people are not going to
be growing and developing to their
Highest Potential as human beings and
that's fine
that's fine uh but it's just like not
whatever
so I don't think it's it's the best
so I mean so far
um you know it seems like most of you
guys are about monogamy and it's what
you demand from a guy when you get into
a relationship but you said that
monogamy's hard for women have you ever
been in a situation
um
where other guys become invisible to you
where you're with a guy that's that
ticks off so many of your boxes that
you're So Satisfied with them you get up
every morning you look at them you're
like this is the best I can do
do other guys ever become invisible to
you and monogamy is not a challenge
oh yeah
yeah
so that's in so that's a circumstance in
which you find yourself where monogamy
is easy is when you're with a guy that
you're happy with
I'm speaking to yes it is easy I'm also
speaking to a place where I haven't been
which is like a long-term marriage with
someone and like stories that I've heard
from women things that I've heard from
wives husbands Etc
um
so and I haven't been there yet but yeah
I I mean anytime I'm with a man like
then it's like I mean that's why I'm
with him I respect him I admire him and
that's that uh Jessica same question for
you with a non-monogamy versus monogamy
how do you handle that like what's your
take on it
like
and the majority of people are Pali but
it's just some people know how to
control him more than others like for
example you could be on a dating app I
wouldn't do a dating app for the fact
that because you get tempted especially
if the person that you with
um doesn't
um give you what that person is offering
you so like let's say I'm in a dating
app and I have my husband or boyfriend
and the in the guy is telling me Oh I'm
gonna buy you a house I'm gonna buy you
a card it's gonna tempt me to actually
talk to him because he's offering me
more than what my husband is giving me
you see so that's why I wouldn't do no
thinking that and I feel like when
people when females or a male have
dating apps or anything with like
outside like where they go out to drink
or they they're tempting they attempting
to talk to other people and be well the
people yeah the Temptation is always
going to be there yeah so I feel like
it's it's hard or and it's sometimes not
hard okay
um Amber I want to hear your take on
this I left you for last because I know
you're gonna have a heart attack that's
okay
um okay right so I actually don't use
dating apps I naturally meet men when I
go out and I've had the best
relationships naturally meeting people
I'm actually very into monogamy I don't
see anything wrong with it I understand
the idea of wanting to venture off and
be with multiple people but that's also
because of social media
face app let's be honest and everything
else out there to make women and men
look better than they actually are I
would rather be one man I don't care if
he's a mid I don't give a any guy
I've ever dated he's always provided me
with exactly what I needed he's always
made me happy I'm very into having a
conservative relationship yes I
understand what I do for a living but
when it comes to relationship values I'm
very big on having one person a
caregiver someone I can rely on someone
that I just feel safe being around I
don't need financial support I just want
someone that that's a man a man so let
me ask you this then because
um you said that you're monogamous and
that you list off a lot of conservative
values that you find attractive that you
desire but what would you say to the
guys out there and I'm sure you've heard
them say this before but Amber you're
sharing pictures of yourself with other
men for 5.99 a month
well I don't do that but
um
on your only fans like are they nudes or
they just feet pictures I do news but I
also actually do very tasteful lingerie
photo shoot so a majority of the content
I sell is actually lingerie
so even so so even the larger issues I
think a lot of guys that you're looking
for that you would deem to be
conservative conventional they'd take
care of you they protect you they take
you out on dates and pay for stuff like
that typical stuff do you do you ever
run into problems where guys are like
look Amber um you know dig your Vibe but
I can't be serious with a woman that
does this I mean like even though it's
just lingerie you're still sharing a lot
of skin out there
actually no
some of them want it to be hot
they actually find it to be hot okay
minus the nudity minus explicit content
when it comes strictly to lingerie me
doing atmosphere events me going to
outings where I'm there showcasing
myself as basically a prop they find it
to be pretty hot because I'm a desirable
woman
and they like being with a woman that's
desire D that's interesting I don't
really have any thoughts on that bud
well I'm kind of curious I mean
why I know it's weird but it's true
no I think my curiosity comes from you
know if you being somebody and I think
everybody on this panel seems that way
like
you want to be the caretaker you want to
be the nurturer to the man and
um I'm just hearing kind of these
conservative values I'm just curious why
previous relationships haven't worked
out
say it in a way that's not like you know
but but I I think you know what I'm
hearing is I'm hearing a lot of
conservative values I'm hearing a lot of
things that most men I think would be
would be down for you know they want to
have if they want their woman to be with
just them and they're looking for a
woman that's not going to be dating a
bunch of different men at the same time
they're they're dating this guy so
that's what I'm kind of curious about
you know what what exactly was the
downfall what exactly
um is the reason that you know these
particular relationships didn't work out
or reasons
so I was actually in a very long-term
committed relationship for four years I
was a stay-at-home girlfriend we went to
church every Sunday I took care of the
house I knew the dry cleaning lady down
history I did everything and I loved the
style the relationship I didn't like the
controlling aspect of it I had limited
spendings and I was limited about the
people I could surround myself with it
was just a very controlling relationship
once that ended I actually went on a
wellness Retreat I discovered myself
learned more about my internal values
decided to try my own thing and let this
worked out quite uh gracefully for me to
be completely honest if I wanted to be
in a relationship I 100 could be but I
chose because of what I do for a living
I know it can be a challenge for most
people and when I signed up for what I
did I was willing to risk that but I'm
perfectly capable with finding a man
that was willing to accept me for who I
am and if he can't then he's not the
right person for me I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out